Iron Man 3 a film everyone agrees is
better than the last one
and that's about it people are split
about whether or not this is actually a
really good entertaining film but once
again it almost doesn't matter because
it stars the person you all come to see
Robert Downey jr. I became to think you
can put this guy as Tony Stark in Batman
and Robin and he would somehow still
make it work but with that aside does
the film actually work as a whole well
it depends on the point of view you're
coming from ok so Tony Stark is back in
his home town after the events of the
Avengers one major downside though is
that now he's getting panic attacks yeah
kind of out of nowhere they try to
explain it that yeah if you go through
this you might get panic attacks too but
I don't know it a little strange that
Tony Stark is getting this I mean this
is a guy that survived terrorist attacks
he had to replace his heart with this
metal light thingy I know they're trying
to add this layer of realism but it
seems a little odd but whatever he's
being threatened by the terrible
Mandarin the leader of a terrorist
organization that vows to take him down
after nearly killing his bodyguard Tony
Stark swears to go after the Mandarin
and does the incredibly foolish thing of
giving him his home address on public TV
for all the world to see with no plan
after that and a friggin shock the
Mandarin comes out to run and blows the
house up this may be the single dumbest
thing a superhero has ever done there's
other good things in the movie I'm gonna
get to it but I just want to go on
record saying that is probably the
stupidest thing in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so Tony is separated from the
world and befriends a small child who
tries to get back on his feet along the
way discoveries are made secret plans
are revealed and of course even more
action and crazy technology starts to
get Gillan
ok so let's once again talk about the
good stuff the action in both Iron Man
movies seemed very minimal and didn't
always play that much to the strengths
of the plot here it's a lot better
there's not only a wide variety of
different action scenes going on but
they're incredibly creative incredibly
funny and don't seem pointless each one
it
the story somehow it's also nice to see
that things are kind of stepping up in
size I mean this is a movie that's
coming off of the Avengers so they know
the guys step up their game a bit and
yeah they kind of do there's a lot of
suits all over the place his house is
blowing up he has to travel alone he has
to start from scratch again but it isn't
just a retread of the first movie either
where he's captured by a terrorist it's
a different kind of being alone even the
idea of a child finding a superhero and
trying to help him out that could have
so easily been terrible but they got a
good child actor and they wrote him
pretty decently and they spent just the
right amount of time on him you think
he's gonna follow Ironman throughout the
entire film and get captured a needs to
save him but no he's in the exact amount
of time he needs to be in it but yeah
let's get to the bad stuff besides from
like I said the dumbest move ever done
in a Marvel movie there's this great
excitement as he Ben Kingsley as this
terrorist fellow this Mandarin guy now
in my comic he's an alien and yeah I
guess you can't really do that here or
could you I don't know the Avengers that
kind of got away with it okay but
whatever I didn't read the comic so I'm
not gonna be a purist
however without giving too much away
what'd they do to this character is
gonna piss off a lot of people this is
like the dance in spider-man 3 or what
they did to Deadpool in Wolverine this
is a complete slap in the face to a
character but with that said it is funny
it was a legitimate twist I didn't see
coming and it did actually get a few
laughs up but again is that what people
are looking for probably not even though
I didn't read the comic I as well wanted
to see the awesome ben kingsley go up
against the awesome robert downey jr.
but instead who do we get some asshole
in a suit again oh my god why do these
guys keep popping up nobody cares if you
wrong someone out of a business or
something it's a comic book movie to
give us comic book villains every time
you always have in these Iron Man movies
they're either embarrassing out too
early or embarrassing again it's kind of
like watching a Batman movie where he's
fighting the Joker and then halfway
through you find out oh the trucker was
a hologram the real mastermind is this
guy who wants to get you for tax fraud
or something who gives a shit we want to
see a comic-book movie especially after
one that's celebrated what a comic book
movie it was with the Avengers so once
again we're stuck with kind of a
half-and-half movie on the one hand the
action is good and is visually
interesting and there's some fun ideas
and Tony Stark is still really funny and
they're evolving him a little bit more
but on the other hand some of these
choices are just so bizarre and so
strange and just downright dumb I get
the idea behind Tony Stark you serve
this tortured genius who has a lot of
brilliance but not a lot of wisdom but
come on some of these moves are just
downright stupid for my money I'm still
glad I saw it again is it technically a
good film kind of hard to say I mean you
still get the Iron Man II stuff you want
to see just a bunch of Technology and
action and smartass lines but yeah it is
a little weird that the best of the Iron
Man movies is the original and even that
heck I have a slow silly second half so
yeah I'm glad I saw it I just want to
see Iron Man 2 what Iron Man does and I
was fine with it but any diehard fans
are looking for that big Iron Man movie
like the big motto a motto fight and
such are probably gonna be disappointed
when they see what's building up - if
you're just a typical movie goer looking
for a typical action film this one's a
lot of fun but if you're looking for the
evolution of a character or a story you
like this movie we'll probably have to
take it step back